hey guys
welcome to this full course on uipath
this video will cover the core topics of
uipath
uipath is the leading robotic process
automation tool
built for both business and i.t uipath
is a tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation for an accelerated business
change
it provides solution for businesses to
automate office routine activities
so if you are interested in rpa and its
tools like uipath
then you are in the right place this
full course on uipath
will help you understand the concepts of
uipath
so here is a list of topics covered
first we will understand
what is ui path its features and
architecture
then we will move on and see the uipath
installation
and install uipath community edition
followed by installation we will in
detail understand the core component of
uipath
that is the uipath orchestrator in this
we will see
how to connect the robot with the
orchestrator
after that we shall understand the
robotic enterprise framework
followed by which we will explore excel
automation using uipath
in which we will create charts and
graphs in excel
and learn how to upload them on the
drive proceeding further
we will see how rpa is used across
different domains
in different fields exploring real time
use cases and examples
and lastly we will look at some of the
frequently asked ui path interview
questions and answers
to crack the interview i'm sure you're
excited to get started with the full
course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and click down the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
let's get started with what is uipath
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
daniel dynes and marius tirka romanian
entrepreneurs
founded uipath in bukharis in 2005.
the first uipath desktop automation
product line was launched in 2013
giving business rpa tools to automate
manual and repetitive back-office tasks
let's look at the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the user of
uipath will develop visual process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace
then with the user interface properties
they can transform those process steps
into a visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool to build web-based or
application workflows
the next feature is record and playback
the user can use this function to record
actions
and transform them into automated
process series
ui path has the following types of
recording options
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop
each activity's complete selector
desktop recording
it can be used for a variety of actions
as well as actions development
web recording it is a common tool for
viewing and recording web page
activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
next we have inbuilt activities in
uipath ui path comes with over 300
built-in activities covering a wide
range of process automation and
application integration design tasks
these activities are found in activities
pane which covers most design tasks such
as data extraction data entry and
automation
next we have advanced scraping options
scraping data from web pages
and applications is easier with ui path
screen scraping
furthermore the data screen scraping
wizard helps in scraping of data with a
repetitive structure
scraping solution works flawlessly with
any program
including.net java flash pdf legacy and
sap
next we have high security and
robustness we can create super smart
durable robots with uipath
with a simple visual canvas everyone in
the company can
use bots uipath offers high security
auto login functionality
to run the bots and operates with a
locked screen allowing automated process
to run in complete privacy
let's look at the components of uipath
the first component we have ui path
studio
ui path robot and ui path orchestrator
let's look at them one by one this is
how a ui path studio looks like
ui patch studio is a user friendly
interface
inside the tool that allows user to
visually plan and design various
automation process
through diagrams using drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks
that must be completed this is the
activity
pane in the ui part studio it consists
of project
activities and snippets
this is the ribbon tab it consists of
saving options opening new files
debugging files recording screen
scraping data scraping and many more
we will explore this in the demo section
next we have output pane where output is
being displayed
and we have the properties pane where
the properties of each activity is shown
here
the next component is uipath robot after
you have built your process
the next move is to put into action in
the ui path studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
process into tasks
which are then executed these robots are
used to assign various tasks and carry
them out in the same manner as
humans but without human interference
when given operation occurs on the
computer ui path robots are programmed
to begin executing tasks automatically
next we have uipath orchestrator the
orchestrator
is a web-based application in ui path it
has features like
deploying monitoring scheduling and
controlling automated bots and process
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software bots
let's look at the architecture of uipath
it consists of two sections
the client side and the server side and
the three layers
let us look at them one by one we will
first look at decline side and the
server side
client-side ui path components are those
that the user or developer can
communicate with directly
uipath studio uipath robot browser and
uipath agent are usually included
ui paths backend operation are
considered server-side
the tasks and workflows that a user
produces are saved in the databases
uipath orchestrator chooses the
necessary function and the software
robots
to carry out the code's task the robot's
logs and statistics are stored in the
backend
logs are useful for analyzing robot
performance and detecting errors
in them the two elements comprise the
uipath robot
agent support for ui path and the
executor service for uipath
the agent support for uipath is a
service in ui path
that serves as the mediator between the
client side and the server side of
uipath
all of the information and data are
conveyed via the handler
messages are also logged into the
orchestrator before being moved to the
sql server
the service can be used to search all of
the currently available tasks in the
device tray
it also can change device settings and
start and stop the current task
execute a service for uipath in this the
software robots use this service to
carry out the tasks specified in the
windows session
now let us look at the three layers
first one is the presentation layer
this ui path components that are open to
the users
make up the client layer ui path studio
robots
browsers ui path agent and executors
for example a user or developer may use
these components
to design and create different tasks
that can be automated
computer robots are commonly used to
complete this task
the client layer is an another name for
the presentation layer
let us look at the service layer the
uipath's architecture's most
significant sheet the cloud layer shows
all server information
the uipath orchestrator is the most
significant part of the server layer
when the robots can perform the task the
entire project is periodically uploaded
to the server
within the aid of an orchestrator the
project is often carried out through
several structures
the orchestrator is in charge of the
whole band it keeps track of the project
development
schedules software robots for execution
and produces summary reports based on
the filtered parameter
it assists in the synchronization of
software robots so that they can
continue to perform routine tasks
it helps our project meet project
requirements service levels and
deadlines
thanks to its web-based management
system
now let us look at the persistence layer
database servers
make up the bulk of this sheet during
this layer
all of the robot's configuration
information is saved
users insert data robots assigned tasks
logging information and assets among the
other items into the orchest status
configuration details furthermore
persistency layer is in charge of
keeping the log information
updated by the uipath agent services
elasticsearch is used to store these
locks the locks are primarily useful for
locating and correcting errors
process level data is usually saved in
relational database management system
such as sql server this makes processing
logs from the vast volume of data a lot
simpler
hence the queues tasks are often taken
care by the persistency layer
let's look at some of the applications
of uipath
in sales in sales ui path is used to
generate invoice
this is an example of data replication
in action
both crm and accounting systems must
have the same sales details
bots can update accounting records
prepare and send invoices from the
appropriate email addresses instead of
manually replicating data
it is also used in keeping scorecards up
to date companies that do not have hr
and crm systems
integrated can use rpa bots to ensure
that crm adjustments are submitted to
scorecards in real time
allowing sales reps to track their
progress
it is used in crm updating a new class
of solution is evolving to incorporate
their email
call and other contact data into crm a
simple bot could be written to update
your crm records with customer contact
information
if you can't find a suitable solution
for using the crm systems
next it is used in banking in banking it
is used to check kyc
though dedicated kyc solutions are
evolving rpa bots can be used to
automate portions of the kyc process
if your organization does not want to
use one
a case may be referred to an employee in
the event of an edge case that requires
human
involvement it is used in sanction of
loans
like most document process activities
this method is appropriate to rpa
automation
because complex business logic can be
embedded in bots
which can partially automate loan
decisions and the manual process
that follow it is used in execution of
trade
rpa bots may be useful in situations
where legacy systems are incapable of
storing complex limit orders
however this is more a band-aid solution
in the long
run switching to a sophisticated and
competent trading system
will certainly be a smart investment
considering how it could increase
trading and minimize trader workload
next it is used in healthcare in
healthcare it is
used for appointment scheduling the rpa
bot makes appointment for patient
based on their diagnosis doctor
availability location and other factors
such as financial statement
and insurance details it is used in
supporting analytics to improve patient
treatment
rpa bots may collect a variety of
medical information
rpa boards for example can use patient
data to a third party healthcare
analytics provider to provide more
reliable diagnosis
and better patient care without
violating any confidentiality
regulations
let's look at the benefits of ui path
increase productivity ui path automates
with quick speed and accessibility
consider an rpa bot that allows a worker
to produce a monthly report in 20
minutes
instead of manually taking 4 hours the
company's productivity could increase as
a result of process automation
next we have high efficiency rps
software
does not need a break it can operate 24
hours a day
a single rpa robot may replace two to
five full time workers
if not more robots can do the same
amount of work in less time or more work
at the same time than humans
customer experience in rpa adopted
business
routine and repetitive and boring tasks
are assigned to robots
allowing employees to focus more on
customer service
company may meet consumer needs with the
help of professional and knowledgeable
employees
highly secure there is no risk of
information leakage from one component
to another
because it performs single task as a
result data access is strictly monitored
and reported
cost effective ui path has minimal
operating cost
and more efficient use of it resources
let's look at the top companies hiring
ui part developers
infosys ibm deloitte
ey kpmg tata
tech mahindra and capgemini
let's look at the salary trends for ui
part developers
the average pay scale for a ui part
developer in
india is 5 lakh 45 000 rupees
ui part developer salary ranges from
three hundred and sixty two thousand
rupees to one million
in usa the uipath developer salary
ranges from
fifty eight thousand dollars to hundred
and seven thousand dollars
and the average salary is seventy six
thousand 000
let's look at a demo consider a scenario
where you have multiple excel files you
want to combine the data in single file
in this demo we will merge two excel
files into a single excel file
and send it over an email let's create
automation to merge two excel files
using uipath
from here we can open a new project or
existing project stored locally or on
version control system
with the click we can open a new project
or create a new project from a template
uipath offers many templates depending
on what you are trying to do
for now let us start with a blank
project
so we'll open a blank project here
so we'll open our main workflow
then we'll go to new and select a new
sequence
we can do it using a flowchart as well
but for now i'll show you
doing a sequence so we'll open the
sequence
and we'll name the sequence since we are
merging two files i'll name it as
merging files
and i'll create
so we'll go to the activities pane
firstly we need to drag and drop a read
csv activity
so search for read csv
so drag and drop read csv activity since
we are using two excel files
so we need to read csv activities
and read from the file we need to select
the file location
so we'll select the file location
sample csv file one
and at the file two we'll select another
file location
sample csv file
at the output side we'll create a
variable
and name it as sl underscore file one
similarly for another csv
we'll create a variable and name it as
sl underscore
file too
so this much is done now we need an
assign activity
so we'll search for assign activity
so we'll drag and drop
assign activity has two parameters two
and enter an expression
so in the two we'll create a variable
name name it as merged
sl and
and in the expression write an
expression
say sl underscore
file 1 dot clone
why are we using a clone function the
clone function creates a new data table
with same structure but does not copy
the data
oops it's showing an error here so
what's the error
so we need to assign the variable type
to be system.data.data table
here we go error has gone
so after using the assign activity we
need to merge the data table so we need
merge data table activity so search for
merge
data table here we go drag and drop it
we need two merge data table activities
so drag and drop
and specify the destination and source
here
the destination is the merged excel
and the source is the sl underscore
file one for the first data merge table
similarly for second merge data table
destination remains same
source will change to sl underscore file
too
so this is done so next we need to drag
and drop a write csv file
write csv file creates an output file in
which you want to merge the two files
so search for
write csv here we go
drag and drop it
so choose the path create the file so
you can see there is no output file here
so we'll create the output file now
which is an empty file
so output dot csv
so we have created an output file
so right from we'll write it as merged
excel
we need the data from merged excel
[Music]
so the output file is created so now we
need to send the file over and mail
so for that we need to drag and drop a
get password activity
so we'll search for get password
activity
there we go drag and drop it
and once you get this
get password activity enter the password
here enter your password
email id password
so there is a prerequisite when you use
get password
to receive a mail go to your google
account
in google account go to your security
option and in security there is an
option called less secure app access
turn that on i'll repeat turn on the
less
secure app access okay once the
get password is done
go to the results section in the result
section
right click and create a variable name
it something maybe sss
so i've created a variable there
so we need a last activity now that is
smt mail message smtp
mail message drag and drop it
so in the host port and enter this
server
so the server you have to enter it as
smtp
dot gmail all should be in the double
quotes
xmtp dot gmail
dot com
and enter the port number as 587
and enter your email id here which is
your own email id i'll enter my
once you enter the email id enter the
password
what we had created
so that's done so enter the email id
here
enter the subject whatever you want
so i'll enter it as merged data
watch excel files
enter the body
so we'll attach the file
so what is the file which we are
attaching
so we are attaching the output file what
we have named it as
output dot csv file
so that's it we'll run the program we'll
run the code
sample execution has started
and within the 10 seconds sample
execution has ended
so we'll go and check if we have
received the mail
so this is my email id
here we go we have received the email
here let's open this
let's open the output file
here we go you can see the data is being
merged
and if you go to the file where the
documents were stored here you go these
were the two files
the sample file 1 and sample file 2 and
this is the most file which was created
let me show you the sample file 1
and sample file 2.
so this is the sample file one with 10
rows
and this is sample file 2 which also has
10 rows
so this is file 2 with 10 rows and file
1 with 10 rows
and here we go this is the output file
which has both 10 10 rows merged here
here we go it is sent over and made
so that's it it was an example
a demo for better understanding of ui
path
in this video we will be looking at the
installation of ui path
so let us see the requirements
we will first look at the hardware
requirements
the cpu should at least have a processor
of 1.4 gigahertz
32-bit configuration or it's recommended
to have a 1.8 gigahertz
64-bit configuration the device
is recommended to have a ram of 8 gb
if not at least a minimum of 4 gb
let us look at the software requirements
if you are using a windows operating
system
then windows should be of version 8.1 or
8.1
n or 10 or 10 n and the windows server
should be of 2012 r2 2016
or 2019 versions another prerequisite is
to have
dotnet framework of minimum of 4.5.2
version installed let us look at the
additions
the different editions that uipath
offers
uipath offers two types of editions
community edition and enterprise edition
community edition is for the developers
and small teams
who are just starting on their
automation journey the enterprise
edition
is further classified into three types
enterprise studio edition
enterprise cloud edition and enterprise
server edition
so enterprise studio edition is for
individual enterprise developers
who want to experiment with ui path
studio price cloud
is a cloud-based deployment of entire
rpa
enterprise platform for any size
business enterprise server
on premises deployment for entire
enterprise automation platform
for large-scale business let us look at
the different profiles in uipath
ui path studio x ui path studio
and ui patch studio pro ui path studio x
is for business users if you are not a
developer
but if you want to automate a simple
task then it is easy to use a studio x
uipath studio it is for rpl developers
build complex automation that is run by
attended or unattended robots
uipath studio pro it is for specialized
developers
automate with the ai advanced rpa
features
testing tools and sophisticated coding
services
so we will look at the installation let
us install uipath
go to any one of the browser and search
for uipath.com
this will take you to the official
uipath website
here you can see try uipath for free
click here
since i have already registered before
it is showing as continue to existing
organization
if you are visiting this website for the
first time then
you might have to register or sign in
using an email account
after signing in and filling all the
details you can continue
here you can see download ui patch
studio
click on this and download the ui path
studio
here you go the ui patch studio setup
file is getting downloaded
once the ui path file is downloaded run
the setup file
and here you can see the ui path is
getting installed after
installation it will ask for a license
select community license
which is free after selecting the
license you need to choose a profile
there are three profiles ui patch studio
pro
which is the advanced studio ide it has
features like testing tools
advanced rpa features and coding
services
another profile is uipath studio it is
for developers
who have clear programming experience
and the last profile is the ui path
studio x
it is for the people who don't have any
programming experience
so we will select uipath studio x for
now next ui path will ask you to update
the channel
you can either select the stable version
or preview version
we will select the stable version for
now after you select the versions
you need to select the source control
plugins you can enable git
version control system or apache sub
version
and azure develop server ui path
provides a
short introduction video tutorials to
learn how to build
automations following step by step
instructions
and an academy to take free training on
the uipath academy
so that's it you have successfully
installed ui path studio
from here you can open a new project new
template
and start building the first automation
what is ui path orchestrator
ui uipath orchestrator is a web
application
that allows you to orchestrate the
execution of repetitive business process
by ui path robots orchestrator
manages the creation monitoring
scheduling
and controlling of automated bots and
process
it serves as a point of integration for
third-party solutions and applications
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling
all software bots it can manage the
entire robot fleet let's look at the
orchestrated capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots
and the web application deployment
deployment ensures that the correct
package versions are delivered to the
assigned robots for execution
configuration configuration looks after
the maintenance
and delivery of the robot environments
and process
configuration queues queues ensures that
the workload is distributed
automatically across robots monitoring
monitoring manages user permissions and
keeps track of robot recognition details
logging logging logs are stored and
indexed in a sql database
interconnectivity interconnectivity
functions as a centralized contact point
for third-party solutions or
applications
let's look at the orchestrated use cases
the strength of uipath orchestrator
comes from its ability to control the
entire robot fleet
let's look at the different use cases
the first is attended this type of robot
is activated by user events
and operates at the same workstation as
a human
orchestrator is used with attended
robots to provide a centralized process
deployment
and logging medium unattended
in virtual environments robots can run
unattended
and automate a variety of process the
orchestrator
is in charge of remote execution control
scheduling
and support for work use in addition to
the attended robot capabilities
studio or studio x they have unattended
robot capabilities
but it should only be used to connect
your studio or studio x
to the orchestrator for creation
purposes
non-production robots are similar to
unattended robots
but they can only be used for research
and development
attended unattended non-production
studio
and studio x robots can all be operated
from a single location
let's look at the orchestrator user
interface
dashboard enables us to see charts and
statistics
illustrating usage information for all
the orchestrator components
like process assets queues
schedules robots jobs and transactions
let's look at the tenant context to view
and control the tenant level entities in
your orchestrator
pick tenant from the sidebar menu with
only one instance of the orchestrator
multi-tenancy allows you to isolate data
these features help you to automate
various departments within your
organization
while also ensuring that orchestrated
data is approved according to your
preferences
please bear in mind that all of the
information is contained in this same
database
let's look at the components one by one
robots a robot is an execution host
that runs uipath studio process you can
add robots
edit them display the status and license
state
adjust the environment they are assigned
to and change the runtime settings on
the robots tab
you can also see the logs that a single
robot has created
process can be downloaded and executed
automatically by robots using custom
settings
while building or editing a robot you
can configure automatic process
downloading
logging level font smoothing and
resolution in the settings tab
folders folders give you a fine grained
control
over automation and their associated
organizations
as well as staff through the entire
organization
in the orchestrator there are two types
of folders
classic and modern classic folders
functionality is allowed by default
while modern folders functionality must
be enabled by the host
or the tenant administrator
users a user is an individual with
access dependent capabilities whose view
and control of the orchestrator
are determined by the access rights
granting
users can be developed and managed
either locally in the orchestrator
or an external directory
roles in orchestrator the roles tab
help you to handle user permissions the
orchestrator view
that a consumer has is defined by the
role they have been assigned
a function allows you to control view
edit
create and delete permissions on all
orchestrator pages
and modules machines
a machine page allows you to provision
and control machines
in preparation for registering robots
with the orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in operation
as well as their forms it allows you to
create your computer
whether it's standard or a template
packages all projects published from ui
patch studio
and those manually imported are
displayed on the packages tab
you can display all available versions
of any package on the packages tab
as well as the status claims and release
notes if they are available
ml skills ml skills retrieves and
request
machine learning skills from the ai
fabric service
it authenticates the robot that is
running the machine learning skills
audit the audit page shows the audit
trail
for all acts taken by orchestrator
entities
several criteria including component
user action and time can be used to
filter
the data on the audit page credential
stores
a credential store is named location
inside a safe store
such as cyber arc where you can get
robot credentials
and credential assets when you need them
at the tenant stage
orchestrator encourages the users of
several credential stores
webhooks webhooks make it easier to
integrate your uipath automation
with the rest of your app ecosystem
you can subscribe to the orchestrator
events and have them sent to the
external dcm
bpm or crm solutions to notify various
users about the new queue items
that can be processed cause failures or
process
updates license
robot licensing is available both at the
host and the tenant level
in the orchestrator on the license list
this enables you to shorten your
deployment time and handle activation
from a single location
within a single click you can trigger
renew
delete and delegate licenses
alerts notifications for robots
queue objects triggers tasks procedures
and activities are shown on the alerts
tab
you will receive updates from all of
your folders on this tab
and you will not be able to choose more
granular options alerts are sent in real
time
and can be categorized as info success
warn error or fatal
settings you can adjust various settings
on the settings tab
including the time zone email warning
information
account information package feeds and
interactive authentication
now let us look with respect to the
folder context
from the sidebar menu pick any available
folder
to view and control the entities within
that folder
automations contains the following tabs
process jobs triggers and locks
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages
manage existing process and keep all of
your process
up to date with the latest package
versions
this allows you to spread packages
through the entire organization uses
and robots and execute process more
quickly from the jobs task
jobs on a uipath robot a job represents
the execution of a procedure the
execution of a job can be started
in either attended or unattended mode on
attended robots
you can't run a job from the
orchestrator and they can't run under a
locked computer
triggers triggers allow you to run jobs
in a predefined sequence
at predetermined intervals and if a new
products are added to your queues
logs the locks page shows you all of the
robot logs
in all of the folders you have access to
to access the locks tab you must have
view permission on the locks
locks are kept in the local database if
the orchestrator is in
accessible monitoring monitoring
contains the following tabs
machines process queues and sla
machines displays information about all
the existing run times
on an aggregate basis and allows you to
check the overall health
of each runtime process the process page
allows you to build new process
from the uploaded packages managing
existing process and keep all of your
process up to date
cues a queue is a storage container that
can accommodate an infinite number of
objects multiple types of data such as
invoice information or customer
information may be stored in queue
objects other systems such as sap or
salesforce
can be used to process this data by
default the data stored in and output
from the queue items is in free form
sla displays sla and risk sla
information
for all queues in the current folder
with sla predictions allowed
this allows you to determine if the
newly added queue items
will be processed on time and if so what
resources you will need to devote to
ensure that their sla
is not violated when the sla is in
danger of not being reached
you will be adequately informed so that
you can make the required changes
queues use contains the following tabs
queues and review request
in the queues pages click on the review
request tab
to show revision request the page shows
items in different queues that have been
allocated for revision
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials
that can be used through several
automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
storage buckets rpa developers may use
storage buckets
to provide a per folder storage solution
when building automation projects
the storage buckets page shows you your
current bucket configuration
and allows you to build as many new
storage buckets as you need
testing testing contains the following
tabs
test sets test cases test execution
test schedules and test data cues
test set a test set is a collection of
any number of individual test cases
each intended to serve a specific
function
the test sets page list of new currently
available test sets and allows you to
build new tests
updating existing ones and run them
test cases the test cases page shows
all of your test cases from all of your
projects and app versions
in one place these are the test cases
that are used in
and to make up your test sets
test executions your previously executed
test sets and their information
are shown on the test execution tab
since test sets are often subject to
change
test executions act as an immutable
record of any given test set's execution
at a given point in time
test schedules allow you to run test at
predetermined intervals
and in a scheduled manner test data
queues
using test data queues you can store and
manage your test data
the test data queue serves as a
container for queue items
that are ready to be consumed via
various activities
the test data queue items are uploaded
or deleted
based on the first in first out concept
action catalogs task catalogs are task
containers
that allow you to categorize your task
using a variety of criteria
the catalog where a task is stored is
defined when the task is created using
studio's build type
task operation in orchestrator
the catalog must be specified first if
you mention a catalog that has not been
generated in the orchestrator
the task is created in orchestrator
without a catalog
settings setting contains two tabs
permissions and machine permission a
user
is an individual with access dependent
capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the roles
assigned to them
users may be installed locally in the
orchestrator or an external director
machines you can use the machines page
to provision
and manage system entities which you can
then use to bind ui path robots to the
orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in use
as well as the types machines are global
tools
which means they can be accessed from
any folder
let's look at the demo in this demo we
will see
how to connect uipath robot with the
orchestrator
how to run workflow using the
orchestrator
let's go to the browser in the browser
enter platform.uipart.com
this will take you to the uipath.com
website
if you have already an account sign in
enter the password
click on sign meanwhile
open the ui path assistant so this is
the uipath assistant
so uipath robot is a kind of
representative
which runs the workflow so we create a
workflow in the uipath studio
then we upload it on the cloud
orchestrator then we configure different
robots to run this workflow
now that we have logged in to the
orchestrator
go to the admin
so you need to click here to add tenant
for the ui path community free edition
you can add only one tenant
so i have already created a tenant so
this
option is disabled for me so when you
click
on the add tenant for the first type the
tenant window will be displayed
then fill the tenant name password and
confirm the password
and it will ask you for name surname and
email address which is optional
so after filling the details click on
provision the tenant and the tenant
admin
are created and displayed in the tenants
page so as you can see the tenant
is created there is an option here users
and groups
you can go to the users and you can see
the different users
so this is my user this is me now you
can go to
the groups and see the different groups
allocated
and their licenses so now that we have
created a tenant
i have named it and enters admit let's
open it
meanwhile you can open ui path assistant
open ui path assistant this is the ui
path robot
there are two different ways to connect
robot to the orchestrator
one is signing in the uipath assistant
it will take the token from the ui path
orchestrator
by user authentication and it will
directly connect machine and the robot
and the other way is to manually connect
so we'll
sign in
enter the password
now you can see here robot is connected
to the orchestrator
so when you sign in the robot will get
connected to the orchestrator
you can go here in the preferences
go to the orchestrator settings and you
can see connected
and licensed so let's go to the
orchestrator in the orchestrator go to
the tenant context
and here you can see the robot is
connected
it's enabled if you go to the machines
you can see the machine is also
connected
so you can see here
there is an unattended robot here
so to get this unattended robot what you
have to do is
go to the users
select the user which you are using this
is my username
go to edit
and here you should enable this
unattended robot enable this option
and enter the username to get the
username you can open the command prompt
and enter who am i so you will get the
username
copy paste the username enter the
password
and click on update and the unattended
robot will get created
so that is how you create the unattended
robot
now that we have connected robot to the
orchestrator
let's open the ui patch studio we'll
create a workflow
and then we'll run it using the robot
so now we have opened the ui path studio
let's open a blank process
after opening the ui patch studio click
on open main workflow
first we'll drag and drop a sequence
then we need a input dialog box we'll
drag and drop
input dialog box enter a title
let's say we'll enter it as ui uipath
orchestrator
enter the input label we'll enter it as
enter your name
let the input type b as text box let's
create a variable say we'll name it as
name and let the variable type be string
and the scope is in the sql scope we
have created the variable
so the value entered should be the
variable view
now we'll drag and drop message box
from set should be displayed
so you enter a caption for the message
say bait
welcome
and enter the text let's say
hi
and we need to concatenate it with the
variable names
will say thanks for watching
this video
so here we go we have created a workflow
now we need to publish this in the
orchestrator so you can see a option
here called publish
click on the publish button so you can
see the package name
the version the new version
and all the other things click on the
publish button
so the workflow is successfully
published
so the name is blank process 3 and
version is 1.0.60
so let's go to the orchestrator
in orchestrator go to the my workflow
folder context in this go to my packages
if you go here you can see refresh it so
here you can see blank process three
so process what we did now it was
published three minutes ago
let's go to the process and the version
what we published was 1.0.16
so the name was blank process 3.
let's start the job you can
change the job priority we'll keep it as
normal the other things is default the
process name and the job type
let's let's execute this process one
time
click on start as you can see
command send for blank process 3 so here
you can see
it is getting run
here you can see it is asking for uipath
orchestrator what we entered title and
enter your name
let's enter some name say sam
will click ok so hi sam thanks for
watching this video
there you go the message is being
displayed like normally in ui patch
studio we click on the run button
and run the workflow but here we have
published it in the orchestrator
and through the orchestrator through the
robot we are
running it and the message is displayed
what is
framework and its purpose
the framework is intended to serve as a
blueprint for users to create process
that provide at a bare minimum a way to
store
interpret and easily change project
configuration data
as well as robot exception handling
scheme and event logging for all
exceptions and related transaction
information
the system locks messages at each
relevant stage
in the process of resolving a business
transaction
and sends those logs to the orchestrator
server
this in turn can be linked to the elk
stack which is elastic search
log stack and kibana platform which
allows for data storage
and a variety of different ways to
represent the data
the purpose of our framework is to
resolve a set of business transaction
a transaction is a small amount of data
and the steps needed to process it
to complete a segment of business
process a process
that reads a single email from a mailbox
and extracts data from it
is a good example what is a business
process
the sum of actions by which the data
required for a series of transactions
is collected processed and input into
or out of an itd source is referred to
as a business process
we can classify business process into
three groups
based on the steps involved and how they
are repeated
linear the steps of linear process are
only done once
and if different data needs to be
processed the automation must be run
again
iterative the steps of iterative process
are repeated several times but different
data items
are used every time transactional
transactional systems like iterative
process
have steps that replicate several times
over various data objects
what is re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
the template includes several
ready-to-use state containers
for launching applications retrieving
data processing it
and closing the transaction these states
are linked together by a series of
transactions
that cover almost every requirement in a
typical automation scenario
several workflows have been triggered
each of which deals with a different
aspect of project
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices
for logging exception management
application initialization
and other areas showing it to handle
even the most complex business
situations
let's look at the features of re
framework the three features are
settings
logging and business application
exception
settings during the initialization phase
of several process
some configuration settings and
configuration values are frequently read
like urls to the web application
orchestrator queue names
and default logging messages the re
framework maintains the track of this
information
by reading it from a configuration file
and storing it in a different dictionary
object shared by all states
instead of updating workflows directly
this provides a simple
way to manage projects by adjusting
values in the configuration file
logging the built-in locking mechanism
is another helpful feature of re
framework
a majority of system workflows use log
message activities to output information
about what is happening at each stage of
execution
this can be used to not only identify
problems
and aid in the debugging process but
also to generate visualization
and reports about the process execution
like how many invoices are handled every
day
how many failures occur and what are the
critical causes of this failure
business and application execution
there may be conditions that occur
during the execution of most process
that are not part of the usual execution
flow and must be resolved to achieve
more efficient automation
if the issue can be resolved by
restarting application
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
such exceptions are known as application
exception
if the issue is with the data or an
underlying business requirement
the system skips the transaction and
moves to the next
such exception are known as business
exception
let's look at the re framework
architecture
the rb framework is implemented as a
state machine
which is a form of workflow with two
advantageous characteristics
states and transitions actions to be
taken in response to the stated input
are described by states transitions that
switch the execution
from one state to another based on the
results of the state
there are four key states in re
framework that is
initial state get transaction data
process transaction and end process
initial state initialization this is the
point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings
and runs application tests to ensure
that all of the prerequisites for the
process start are met
so initialization transitions so there
are two transition
system exception and successful when
system
exception when a system error is not
nothing
it gets transition to the end process if
we have an application exception during
the initialization phase
we don't have enough details to start
the process as a result
we are going to the end process state to
wrap it up
successful when a system error is
nothing it gets transition to get
transaction data
if during the initialization we have no
error then we go to the
get transaction data the next state is
the get transaction state
this date retrieves the next transaction
object this can be a queue item or a
collection item
transaction items are queue items by
default but this can be modified
to meet your needs this is also the
state where the developer can set the
condition to exit the state
when there are no items to process get
transaction data transitions there are
two transitions
no data and new transaction
no data if the transaction item is
nothing
then we are at the end of our data
collection so we go to the end process
new transaction data if the transaction
item contains data
then we process it next state is the
process transaction state
the process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in the
previous step
it performs actions and applies logic in
various application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item that is available
so there are three process transaction
transitions
success business exception and system
exception
in success if the condition is business
rule exception is nothing
and system error is nothing then the
transition to get transaction data
if there is a business role exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transition
business exception if the business ruled
exception is not nothing
then it gets transition to get
transaction data
if we have a business rule exception we
log it and move to the next transaction
by going to the get transaction data
state system exception
if we have an application exception we
close all programs
kill them if they fail to complete take
a screenshot at the moment
the exception happened and go to init
where we re-initialize our working
environment and begin a new
form of transaction that has failed and
finally we have the end process date
the procedure is completed and the
application opened during the automation
are closed in the
end process state since this is the last
state the final state there are no
transition available
in the end process state we'll explore
each one of these states in detail in
the demo let's see the demo now
in this demo we will see how to dispatch
data from the excel file
then we will create queue items and
process these items
and then we will understand the working
of each state in the robotic enterprise
framework in detail
so let's get started first we'll go to
the orchestrator and create a queue
enter cloud platform dot
ui
sign up then go to the orchestrator
the tenant which you have created
select the folder context go to the
folder context
and you can see cues here go to the
queues
and you can see a option to add here
click on add and
enter a queue name
[Music]
i'll enter it as ref enter any
description if you want
give unique reference yes and
act and you can see a queue has been
added
so you can add an asset as well to add
an asset you can
go to add click here add
and enter the asset name
[Music]
and select the type whatever is required
say boolean
and by default be it as false and create
so this is how you create an asset so
let's go to the ui path studio so what
we are
basically doing is we are building two
process
one to feed a queue in the orchestrator
that is a dispatcher process
and one to process transaction from the
queue that is using the
robotic enterprise framework so in
dispatcher process
what we do is we get entries from an
excel file and add them as a queue items
in the orchestrator
we have already created a queue we
started project
as sequence and added a try cat we
started with the sequence
added a try catch activity in the try
block
we used a retrench activity to read
first 10 lines
from a1 to c11 from an excel file and
store them in a newly created
data table variable
we used for each row to loop through the
rows of the data table variable
and add each of them in a queue using
the add queue item activity
then we use a log message we use log
message activity
to lock the fact that the dispatching
process was successful
that is how we created the dispatcher
process
now we will create a performer
using robotic enterprise framework what
it does is it get titles from the queue
and processes so
[Music]
in the dispatcher process let's go to
the initialization state first
so we'll understand initialization state
in detail
so the entire index block is kept inside
the try catch
if you go to the documents here and if
you go to the data folder
you can see a config file here
so config file this is the file we use
in the init state
it has three sheets settings constants
and
assets you can give any values whatever
you want
for maximum retry number the value
should be zero
when you are working with the
orchestrator queues the value should be
zero so this config file is stored in
the
data folder
and it has three sheets settings
constants and assets
this is the queue name process abc let's
get back
to the
framework
so we are initializing system error if
the error is nothing
it will go to the next state if first
run read local configuration file
you can see by default there are many
variables created
you should know them and utilize them
whenever required
the config variable the value type is
dictionary type
config is nothing if you go here
you can see here config is nothing
initially there is no value so initially
config is nothing then it will input
init all settings workflow
let's open this first run
so it will invoke init all settings
workflow
to see this workflow click on open
workflow
it has three arguments
it has three arguments in config file in
config sheets and
out config this is of type string
type string and out config is of type
distance
and direction this is a both our input
and this is
out let's open the workflow and
understand
so basically what this workflow does is
this workflow outputs setting dictionary
with the key value
pairs to be used in the project settings
are referred from the local config file
and then fetch from the orchestrator
assets assets will overwrite the config
file settings
fitting in it all settings workflow
invoked to initialize all settings and
data for application and process use
in this part the setting constant and
assets in the config
file from the data folder are read in
the initialize all settings
so let's go back the orchestrator queue
name
from the from the configuration file in
the argument case
is specified and it provides a backward
compatibility
next we have invoked process
if we go to the arguments here
we can see the orchestrator queue name
you can assign a queue name here if you
have created a queue
so invoke kill process next we have
invoke kill process
it is a logging activity called killing
process depending on the project you can
add active
it is a logging activity called killing
process depending on the project you can
add activities
and add log fields in ad lock fields if
you want to add any details in the log
file
then you can do it using all log fields
init all applications
workflow in this workflow invoke to open
apps and check the status credentials
and
so on and that there are two transitions
in this when it is
successful it gets transition to get
transaction data
when there is a system exception it goes
to the end process
so so in short what initialization state
does is
at the end of this workflow that is the
initialization state it reads the config
file and
stores the key and value inside the
dictionary that is the out config
what config dictionary variable has all
config excel file data let's
see the get transaction data
when you are in the orchestrator and you
want to immediately stop a job from for
some reason when the job is stopped
this activity gets activated there is a
variable
created should stop if it's a boolean
variable
by default it's false when it gets
activated the value becomes
yes then it will go to the log stop
message as
stop process requested
and it will end the process when the
transaction
item is nothing else it will go to the
try get transaction data
here it has seven arguments
and let's see the workflow invoke the
transaction data workflow
click on open workflow
it gets the data from the spreadsheets
databases email web api or ui path
server use
if no new data items then set out the
transaction item to
nothing if a new transaction item is
retrieved then it gets the additional
information about it it gives the
condition
where our transaction item is not
nothing then it will add the transaction
information to the log fields
it is about the get transaction data
workflow
the process transaction state the
process is a sequence with a try catch
activity
set to catch both system exceptions and
business exceptions
inside the try block the process
transaction workflow
invoked that has simple process like to
attach the ui demo application
and three type into activities to fill
in and
click accept button
and if you see look at the transitions
it has three transition
system exception whose destination is
the initialization state
business exception goes back to the get
transaction data
and success it goes to the get
transaction
data finally the end process state where
the applications
is closed what is excel automation
excel automation is a task automation
involving excel files
studio x enables the creation of
automation
project involving various types of data
from an excel
file using various specialized
activities
to create an excel automation we must
use excel file resource
when creating a new project that
includes excel
an excel file must be specified within
it so that all of the subsequent actions
can access the data contained within
that file
why use an excel automation uipath
allows
you to automate excel in various ways
such as
excel application scope activities and
workbook activities
excel automation simplifies your
application
by performing tasks such as formatting
cells
updating values and running macros
automatically
excel task in automated process can also
be
integrated with several other functions
across the enterprise using an rpa
solution
the benefit of excel automation in
general is that
it can save people many are spent
manually completing tasks
advantages of excel automation
productivity excel automation provides
higher production rates
and increased productivity efficiency
some of the functions of excel can
easily create automated tasks
and custom logic with functions like
macros
macros are an excellent way to save time
on predictable
repetitive tasks hence excel automation
is efficient
better product quality excel automation
improves quality in several ways
including eliminating human error
increasing consistency and accuracy
the ability to create more complex
projects and the detection of mistakes
along the way
improved safety excel allows you to
protect your work
whether it's to prevent someone from
opening a workbook without a password
to grant read-only access to a workbook
or to simply
preserve a worksheet so you don't delete
any data
reduced labor excel automation will
perform all the repetitive tasks more
accurately and productively than humans
thus reduces labor reduced lead time
a lead time is the amount of time that
elapses between the start and finish of
a process
excel automation reduces the lead time
let's look how to install an excel
package
let's jump into the uipath studio to
install an excel package
go to the manage packages
you can see the packages that are
installed go to all packages
and search for uipath excel activities
by default an updated version will be
installed if the excel package is not
installed you can install it from here
so in my device
this activity is already installed
this is the place from where you can
install any
activities or any packages
let's see some of the commonly used
excel activities
these are some of the commonly used
excel activities
redrain select range save workbook
autofill range copy paste range
insert and delete columns so insert
inserting a column
at the specified location in a sheet or
a table
or a range and to delete a column
you can delete it from a specified range
or the table
there are filters filter table so what
filters does is
you can use the filter action to create
a filter in a range table
or a sheet based on the values in a
single column
we also have vlookup vlookup which
stands for vertical lookup
is an excel feature that when enabled
searches
and retrieves data from a specified
column we will explore
all of these activities in the demo
section in detail
let's look at the demo in this demo we
have an excel
sheet that has a record of kovitt cases
in five states of india
in 2021 so we will create an excel
automation to represent the number of
cases
in charge it's easy to understand
looking at the charts
rather than looking at the huge numbers
then we will upload the file on the
drive so
let's jump into the ui studio and get
started
this is the excel file which i have
created
it has all the number of cases in this 5
states
in the year 2021 the month of jan feb
march and
april all this record i have taken it
from a website called
prsindia dot org
so i have two sheets sheet1 and sheet2
so let's jump into the uipath studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages
installed one is the uipath
excel activities package the other one
is uipath g suite dot
activities this activity this package is
used for
drive topload on the drive then
the other package is balareva excel
activities
this package is used for bar graph
and pie chart
so after installing these three
packages we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence 2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is
it opens an excel workbook and sets the
scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and excel application
are closed when the workbook application
variable
is specified in the output workbook
activities field
the spreadsheet is not closed
this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range so the range is
in this excel sheet ranges from a1
to f5 so enter the range
for this we need to enter the
file path so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file we have
entered the
enter the table name say
number of cases
[Music]
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a
bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope
and select the file path so
select the file
so select the file select this cell
range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1 to f5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3d clustered 3d stand
whatever is required for now we will
select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want
so i'll keep the size as
350
to 350 you can change the width
[Music]
so the bar chart is done and you can
enter the sheet
which sheet are you using so it's sheet1
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show that
select show value
and select the sheet which you are we'll
select the sheet 2.
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive
so we'll select this option upload file
select the file
so we have selected define so select the
destination folder
for that go to your google drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
here not the entire properties
and go to your ui patch studio
and paste it in the destination folder
give your double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error we have forgotten
to use a
g suite application this can be only
used inside a g-suite application
so drag and drop a g-suite application
and inside g-suite application
will write this so there is god
so we'll run the file now we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is added we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded
will open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one with the values
number of values and each state wise and
for sheet two
we created a pie chart so here we go
here you can see the purchase
in this video we will be looking at the
robotic process automation example
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement a
customer representative
must understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data
sometimes asking for information that
has already been requested
this tends to decrease customer
satisfaction and extends call duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing rpa solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems
the customer service representative can
launch a bot
the bot completes all actions in seconds
with the press of a button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created
a customer service representative will
fill out the necessary information
to receive the queries and bots will use
that data
in multiple systems to complete the
transaction
let's look at an example consider a
scenario
where a company was providing support to
the client and the company
was supposed to handle a large number of
calls
approximately 20 000 calls per month
which required a significant amount of
time spent in the support team
because of the system's complexity an
executive's average time was about 10
minutes
the system was inefficient and slow
resulting in the poor customer service
with the rps solution the organization
gained a virtual team
that can complete the task in less than
a minute resulting in a drastic
reduction in an execution time
the rpa board performs the following
task loading a comprehensive customer
profile
obtaining a detailed billing information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated
resolving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
financial service
financial service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments
and storing the records in a system data
is manually extracted from a bank
statements
to reconcile documents and link them to
its forms using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
excel legacy software
and manual labor which is tedious and
time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds
prompting clients to pay more quickly
rpa
in financial services tracks and
standardizes
and validates payments process orders
and avoids errors
and is always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant
makes the customers experience less
stressful adding value to the service
provider
rpa in finance eliminates the need for
endless email correspondence
and ensures a smooth payment approval
process matches invoices
to responsible parties and sets deadline
reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process
and relieves human employees of huge
tasks this enables precise and
structured
invoice processing consider a financial
service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently
and accurately in order to generate
ratings
using rpa company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data
this enable decline to quickly and cost
effectively automate
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
financial service are
investment management reconciliation of
bank statements
organizing the finances record of
accounts receivables and pay
the third example is hr service this
operation
includes numerous routine steps such as
interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shot listing
induction training and onboarding airing
and firing place a significant burden
on hr and other support functions such
as i.t
security and facilities management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution
that encompasses all of these functions
and completes the necessary tasks for
new or departing employees
some employees can be sloppy with
recording absences vacation
or in general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is rpa
can be used to collect and screen
resumes
and online application forms contact
through background checks
and compare the information to all the
relevant job requisitions
this allows the best candidates to be
shortlisted
rpa can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees
that are both personalized and accurate
and also validate records
by cross-checking data such as absentees
reports
against time logged in the corporate
network and alerting when information is
missing or inconsistent
talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees previously the
onboarding paperwork was completed
manually
by one person consuming a significant
amount of employees time
that could have been spent on more
valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day
the company understands that an hr
department wants to provide a digital
and straightforward experience the task
required a lot of copy and paste
activities with the implementation of
rpa
the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time
allowing hrs to spend more time on
corporate social responsibilities
hiring talent initiatives and improving
a company's reputation
the tasks performed by rpa bots in hr
service are
screening resumes onboarding of new
hires
attendance management induction and
training
employment management and survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
service delivery
thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies
looking to improve their customer
service high reliability and accuracy of
process outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
automation in telecom
reduces error rates to close to zero
improves data quality
improves customer service and increases
operational efficiency
all while contributing significantly to
cost reduction
rpa technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees
based on the employee section a
well-structured workflow can be
generated
which serves as the foundation for
automated process by mapping each
process step with its significant cost
for manual execution
it is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and media company
decided to automate its order creation
and service removal process
to cut costs associated with the company
speed booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of rpa it
becomes simple
to automate the order build process and
service removal activity
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
telecom service are
it checks on the credit and sim card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints
porting customer phone numbers
responding to questions
from partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
healthcare systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation
such as claim management this results in
high operational cost
and slow process every industry has
inefficiencies
but few face the healthcare industry's
challenges
strict regulations regarding patient
data and lack of resources
to deal with such rules building takes
time after a health care service is
provided due to manual and repetitive
task in the management process
management process include document and
data input processing
and evaluation in addition to the
automating time consuming task
patients can schedule appointments
without the intervention of hospital
employees
credit to rpa technology along with
eliminating the need of resource
allocation for scheduling
by allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly
this application can improve customer
relations rpa allows healthcare
providers to track and document each
process step
in structured log files to comply with
external audits
rpa improves data confidentiality
because boards handle this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization
deals with the process of patient
transaction data customer detailed
recording
claims to the process and data
reconciliation for health care schemes
are some of the manual process they must
streamline daily the primary goal was to
increase the efficiency of
existing approaches to achieve greater
accuracy
with reduced turnaround time robotic
process automation was implemented
and the most significant possible impact
was obtained
rpa platform handled claims processing
and health data reconciliation program
healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
healthcare service are
appointment scheduling regulatory
compliance
data entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment
so with that we have come to the end of
this full course tutorial
if you enjoyed watching it make sure to
hit the subscribe button
and press the bell icon to never miss an
update
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
you